hey everyone its Ilana or Charl Amazon
and this is my first time making a vlog
because some of you guys were like hey
Ilana you should make a day in the life
of video and I was like hey better just
be me sitting on my bed over there so
instead I thought I would make a video
for something that actually is kind of
exciting and that is the 200th episode
of my radio show so I'm going there now
for those who don't know I'm on the
radio every week it's one of my many
jobs and we review video games
so let's go so we're in my lovely little
hunk of really old rusty dirty car right
now which he's a hundred integra vti off
for those who I wandering it's slightly
modified because I'm cool like that so
the car trip is finally over this video
is gonna have a lot of driving someone
might even say it's like gta5 am i right
so we're looking at right now is the
exterior of one or two point one of them
it's pretty awesome
so this is the studio where things
happen in this corner we have Jody who's
on his phone over there we have monster
razor he likes that and then we have Lee
and in this corner we have candy hi so
how do you feel about 200 episodes ray
you started this does anyone else feel
good about 200 episodes how long have
you been here fully yeah that one other
show bunch of jacks
all right who's Mike hello welcome
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
animals and plants to another episode of
Zed games but let's kick this episode
off as usual with the week in gaming
news headlines miscanti pain Thank You
Raisa YouTube has responded to outcry
from the YouTube gaming community after
thousands of gaming related videos were
flagged for copyright infringement every
single prize one big special
announcement I make before I go is right
now on iTunes itunes store so as much as
I believe that iTunes is like the prison
warden of the Apple ecosystem like the
number one way to get podcast so yes
search for those it's time for Darkseid
Mike struggles ed why don't you put one
effects
most embarrassing it's a good song
breakdown all right yes sir like I said
we're on iTunes now I've checked it out
it's working fine what do people have to
search just set games yeah so that's
that's good next year a lot of content
for the first few weeks which being this
old enjoy business and IRL true to those
guys who that sounds really cool yeah
that's like a whole [ __ ] you get to use
for the first few weeks let's sort of
fill in that dead zone while we don't
have any games for you so that was a
fairly cool episode of set games I'll
leave a link below right away you can
hear that episode or other episodes and
all that other promotional goodness and
that's the last episode of this year so
I can do whatever I want a Wednesday
nights now I don't know what I'm gonna
do but thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed this super random and
really unorganized video that you guys
requested for whatever reason don't
blame me for this mess I'll see you guys
next time I don't know what this is
it's a TV but it has some really